have noticed I was talking about before
the break that once I had built some
wealth and had an emergency fund that I
had fewer emergencies it just seems like
to there's something some kind of a
correlation between getting your
financial act together and just getting
your act together growing up being smart
around all it's like when I start doing
stop doing stupid stuff with money I
stop doing as much stupid stuff in
general does that make sense and so I
really have as soon as we got an
emergency fund I remember the first time
we got our emergency fund to ten
thousand dollars after we went broke and
started completely over and you know we
had little kids in the house they're
wearing consignment sale clothes and
we're scratching and clawing Sharon's
couponing and we finally get that first
time we get to a thousand a ten thousand
dollar emergency fund I'd never had ten
thousand dollars cash in the bank to not
touch for any reason ever I never had an
emergency fund I always live just hand
to mouth when I got that emergency phone
in place it was like something relaxed
and sharing something relaxed in me and
we were set in a completely different
place then and we really did stop having
emergencies and I some of it again was
because we had nicer things we were
starting not by then we didn't have
nicer things but we were starting to get
a little bit better this or better that
and you don't wait until the the breaks
are you know completely grind through
the rotor before you get the brake job
you get the brake job done as soon as
you hear the first little sign that
there's bad brakes and so if the brake
job cost you less you don't wait until
the tire blows out before you get new
tires and so a cost you less you'll
destroy the rim when you blow the tire
instead you're looking only we gotta get
new tires and we've actually got money
for tires and so you get tires and by
the way if you get this entire ship
fewer wrecks and there's less wear and
tear on the car and it rides better and
all these other things you know I mean
all this stuff starts to work together
and we started having fewer emergencies
it was like when we got it felt like
that because we got an emergency fund
like Murphy went and bothered somebody
else there was this switch that flipped
it really we have never
really had a big enough emergency in the
last 30 years to get into the emergency
fund now we've had some emergencies but
we just cash flow them
we had a heating air go out and I just
3500 bucks in the old house and we just
wrote a check I remember doing that was
weird but it wasn't I didn't even have
to touch the emergency fund it's like we
had an emergency fund for the emergency
fund and that same little account you
know with money added to it of course
over the years is still just sitting
there it's never really been touched and
part of that was we started making more
money part of that was we started having
better stuff and not having to do the
repairs like I said earlier part of it
was though there's something that
happens in your life that when you get
your act together with your money you
just get your act together and you just
stop doing and living in such a way that
you invite crazy crap into your brain
and into your life this intersection and
get what's going on it's just crazy hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]